hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday January 20th 2020 what's
going on how all right it's Sunday night
and there's like five minutes to go in
the San Francisco 49ers you know and
they are winning 34 to 20 Packers just
got a got a pass interference call a
data not here they did not care for well
you know what my bike my dams my sports
Bay Sports Day did not go the way that I
wanted to it started off with the Boston
Bruins yet but at that the bad bet I
started off with the Boston Bruins going
up three to nothing on the always
dangerous Pittsburgh Penguins who got
Sidney Crosby back the day before they
played this before all but no and
everything was looking great and then I
took my blush and my wife took me up and
my lovely took us out to brunch so you
know I had my phone off because I want I
wanted to be there I wanted to be
present you know as a father and as a
husband you know so whatever I mean if
I'm looking at a [ __ ] game we're
gonna get an argument okay so I just
shut it off and I was just like I just
watch the rest of it when I get home but
what I forgot was was the NFL playoffs
were on after that and then also I had
to bake my daughter a birthday cake
because today's her birthday and about a
little bottle right so I had to make
sure that I you know I did everything I
could right so whatever so I got home
and somehow they [ __ ] lost 43 so
that's how my day starts all right
[Applause]
Kansas City Chiefs playing Remember the
Titans
from Nashville right I got a root for
Abel but I also you know I felt bad for
[ __ ] Kansas City Chiefs fan they
hadn't been there and so [ __ ] long I
didn't know who to root for everybody
always piles on and II read a day right
now you know he's a great coach but he
can't win the big one he can get you
right there but he can't get you over
though I'm killing yes you're over the
hub where do you place him historically
hey buddy where do they place you
historically you know I said I'll that
question a lot people who have an
accomplished [ __ ] with their life people
can't even grow a mustache let alone
coach your [ __ ] so I was happy for
him I was tweeting a lot during the game
[ __ ] around I was saying how you know
when they they had like during halftime
at Arrowhead Stadium when they pulled
back they had the concourse and was
[ __ ] mob then I was sitting there
laughing to myself thinking there's at
least forty percent of those people are
out there smoking cigarettes it's the
Midwest man okay they think because the
Surgeon General doesn't have a mustache
to go along with his beard therefore
he's a liberal what's the matter what's
that to anybody anywhere nobody I just
oh who is the birthday girl happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear cutie
every birthday to you what how old are
you
what's that free that's right chills up
to three feet yeah before next year all
right can I can I do my filthier so I
can afford to continue buying presents
why are you breathing into the mic
you don't know yeah
get it away all right what are you doing
you can't sit on Mount come on I don't
do edits here so this is like Oh daddy's
just messing around
daddy's being silly yeah I'm being silly
all right all right okay thanks for
checking in on me okay bye bye
no loud equals funny I don't know how to
write a joke bye bye bye alright anyway
so so I turned on the first game right
yes I was watching the Kansas City
Chiefs and you know I didn't yeah and
you know the [ __ ] root for there I
mean I think it can't see he's been
waiting long enough to Nashville doesn't
care that I mean they're still they
still can't believe that they're even in
the NFL right how long they've been
around 20 years c'mon
how long you been waitin Nashville do
you really in your heart of hearts what
do you want to really happen Nashville
to win to win a [ __ ] Super Bowl or do
you want the University of Tennessee the
volunteers to once again rise up to the
well okay you answer that question
honestly we all know what the [ __ ] it is
okay that is a college football [ __ ]
state okay you make your own booze you
like the local kid alright he ain't that
smart but you put a help
right now he's gonna get you some yards
that's what Tennessee is right yeah
everybody's got a car in a barn that
they're gonna turn into a [ __ ]
racecar you're not into the NFL that
that's that's Yankee [ __ ] so I don't
have any sympathy for those [ __ ]
people all right they're too busy trying
to write a hit Nashville huh let's let's
let's write a [ __ ] saga bout I don't
know some guy who got his [ __ ] heart
broken he comes home to an empty house
you know something as parakeet then
[ __ ] slowly dies by the end of the
song that's what they're trying to do
they trying to write the next hit or
something patriotic you know what I mean
get your goods and shoot a pig on your
own property right and ain't no skinny
liberal will thigh hairy [ __ ] you gonna
tell them a different right you put some
[ __ ] harmonies in that you know
smooth out the melody I'm telling you
got yourself a hit you got yourself a
hit yes very happy for Kansas City fans
congratulations your first Super Bowl in
50 [ __ ] years by the way only thing I
can't stand is that stupid Tomahawk Chop
you know it's a [ __ ] embarrassment
that's why you [ __ ] your [ __ ]
mascot looks like a goddamn rat you know
jaysis Christ those [ __ ] people do
the Tomahawk Chop white people imitating
white people imitating Native Americans
being portrayed by white people and a
[ __ ] cowboy and air-quote Indian
movie from the 1930s so [ __ ] stupid
so stubborn so stupid why the [ __ ] would
you do that you know I mean I've always
compared it to like if the Germans
actually won in World War two can you
imagine if they then add a [ __ ] team
called I don't know the [ __ ]
Frankfurt Jews and every time they got
to [ __ ] they scored cuz of soccer Oh
they'd score a goal and then everybody
in the crowd be gone Oh
Oy Vey
huh Jesus Christ have a [ __ ] little
bit of respect
oh my god are they showing the [ __ ]
49 to the one the show last time the
49ers won a Super Bowl this game is over
the show in 1994 when they won [ __ ]
against Stan Humphries staying out
freeze alright there's Jerry Rice loving
every minute every probably still
running that [ __ ] Hill anyway other
than that I enjoyed it so now it looks
like it's gonna be the 49ers first two
Chiefs I got a route for the Chiefs
because they haven't won one in a longer
amount of time although I love seeing
the 49ers great again especially because
they ditched those awful white pants
that's one of the best uniforms in the
league unless it has white pants the
second has white pants it looks like a
cheap [ __ ] suit all right they had
the gold pants with the gold helmet that
[ __ ] beautiful maroon he looks like a
[ __ ] trophy alright anyway so
congratulations to the I guess I'm
calling it early here they are punting
there is 346 left and it is a [ __ ]
NFL game you know I thought it was going
to be a blow up but then you know I have
my conspiracy theory that the NFL does
not allow blowouts no existe you always
have to be within two scores so then
everybody sits down and they watch it
why am I watching this [ __ ] punter
going over to to do what what is this
this [ __ ] James Cameron tracking shot
what the [ __ ] was that for they gonna go
for it are they going for that kill shot
can somebody explain to you what
happened to shoulder pads they used to
have shoulder pads and all of a sudden
yet it's weird and they stop leading
with their helmets and the shoulder pad
look at that lament enough [ __ ] small
the shoulder pads oh this [ __ ] broads
in the 80s with biggest shoulder pads
and their waist length [ __ ] leather
jackets anyway but that is this what I
wanted to talk about is this what I
wanted to discuss no it isn't what I
actually wanted
talk about was all the scuttlebutt here
I guess the punter left there deciding
to go for it they're going for the kill
shot the kick is up and it is good and
that'll do it your San Francisco 49 is
going to the Super Bowl for the first
time since they played the Ravens in
like 2012 I want to say can't remember
all right so here's my question now who
is gonna dance more San Francisco Kansas
City as far as their players who's gonna
dance more the San Francisco 49ers the
Kansas City Chiefs or JLo and Shakira
that's what I want to know who is gonna
celebrate who is gonna have a better
dance routine man I have fun this week
with some Yankee fans that were whining
about the [ __ ] Houston Astros and
that's stupid-ass overblown [ __ ]
down there and [ __ ] Houston you know
what I mean and then typical [ __ ]
[ __ ] New York fans they have such a
small-time [ __ ] town mindset you know
what I mean because the other thing
about New Yorkers people who are born in
New York they didn't have to earn be in
there they just showed up like [ __ ]
rich kids and then they hear all these
songs see all this [ __ ] blowin them and
they just have this [ __ ] sense of
entitlement it's [ __ ] hilarious
okay to [ __ ] sit there this is my
take on the Houston thing why I don't
have a problem with what they did okay I
still congratulate the World Series
champion 2017 Houston Astros and I'm
gonna congratulate them for finally
bringing a gun to a gunfight
all right who's kidding hood now this is
the thing all these [ __ ] Yankee fans
I'm [ __ ] here and beli Aiken they're
all acting like what Houston did just
fell out of the [ __ ] sky everybody
was playing by the rules and then all of
a sudden Houston sticks a [ __ ] camera
in the [ __ ] wall or whatever the
[ __ ] going on right
that's not what happened everybody first
of all they're not the first people that
do it the shot heard round the world way
back in 1951 now Josh where the padded
the Giants win the pennant the Giants by
the pen they had a [ __ ] guy out there
with a telescope relaying signs in
they've had TVs in the [ __ ] dugout
the [ __ ] camera is behind the pitcher
I literally want how many times you
watch games and they're focusing in on
okay when he does that that's a fastball
like some X pitcher telling him what the
[ __ ] signs are okay and lastly
baseball has been [ __ ] up since 1994
okay
they kind of rested on the laurels they
without fight that that is that he say
it's rest on your laurels in Hattie
they [ __ ] were America's pastime okay
before they came along believe it or not
it was horse racing and boxing and then
out of nowhere right baseball comes
along right and starts chugging along
and all of a sudden they are the game
Babe Ruth children as you Hank Greenberg
Stan Musial Willie Stargell Willie Mays
Willie McGee Willie Willie all these
[ __ ] people come along right donator
[ __ ] and whitey Ford Mickey Mantle Roy
Campanella Pee Wee Reese Phil Rizzuto
Ted Williams all these peach Jackie
Robinson Dusty Baker Rowley fingers
Ferguson Jenkins sorry all of these
people come along and everybody's
watching right everybody's [ __ ]
watching and watching they have the
number one sport no man here in and
[ __ ] year out the biggest advertising
Aqua Velva [ __ ] Old Spice all of this
[ __ ] goes to the baseball players and
then somehow in the [ __ ] 1970s
all right after the greatest game ever
in 1958
believe when the Colts played the Giants
in [ __ ] Yankee Stadium that was the
peak that was a turning point a baseball
didn't realize it on came football in
the AFL in the NFL then they [ __ ]
March after Joe Willie oh wait Darren
please right I won't kiss you right they
win it and then the [ __ ] Chiefs come
in I believe that they were the first
like you know when it was the NFL AFL
and merged they win the [ __ ] thing
and then what happened was the super
Steelers the Dallas Cowboys the Dallas
Cowboy Cheerleaders come with their
[ __ ] titties wrapped in scarves
baseball didn't know what the [ __ ] hit
him right and then they had all those
awful baseball stadiums Webb done you so
he seemed on this week in baseball what
up but bad at DePauw right there these
cookie cutter [ __ ] stadiums it just
looked like you know what the [ __ ] it
was anymore and you had the Raiders with
Ken Stabler he had the Pittsburgh
Steelers with [ __ ] Terry Bradshaw you
had [ __ ] yet Roger Staubach yeah it
[ __ ] Fran Tarkenton the purple people
eaters the Domesday defense to Steel
Curtain
they came on with a vengeance right then
the NBA was where the NFL was the
[ __ ] decade before they're dealing
with the [ __ ] ABA everybody stealing
their stars cocaine don't worry I got a
point here cocaine comes out decimates
the [ __ ] League NFL passes the
[ __ ] MLB right and NBA looks like
it's going out then along come Bird and
Magic write save the [ __ ] NBA five
six years into their career [ __ ]
Jordan's coming along you got the bad
boys and then the [ __ ] Bulls but what
the [ __ ] going on at baseball the [ __ ]
is going at different teams winning it
every year yeah just nothing scale
Yankee suck in the 80s at all [ __ ]
levels out and everybody grows up on the
Showtime Lakers and [ __ ] Jordan
dunking on people and Dan Marino lighten
up the [ __ ] 85 Bears on Monday Night
Football
Budda right it all got [ __ ] exciting
and what happened baseball was a game in
the past most our odds ever had Babe
Ruth big fat white guy used to [ __ ]
hookers if he not dogs and go out there
you throw a no-hitter in nineteen
[ __ ] home runs in one game most home
runs ever Hank Greenberg 190 most games
in a row will Gehrig and then he died
and he was happy it happened considered
himself lucky was all about [ __ ]
yesteryear it was a bunch of
thousand-year old white guys with the
[ __ ] records right and they came to a
screeching [ __ ] halt in 1994 and they
had a [ __ ] strike right and then they
sat back and they looked at the game and
they said what the [ __ ] happened huh why
isn't anybody watching why doesn't
anybody want to [ __ ] play why are we
getting a [ __ ] ass kicked by the
goddamn NBA in the NFL and they were
like in our games too [ __ ] slow the
problem what do they do they juiced up
the [ __ ] ball they got thing they
[ __ ] held all these goddamn towns
hostage they got new stadiums juiced up
the ball change the dimensions so
there'd be more [ __ ] offense the
players started doing roids they all
look the other [ __ ] way
right Cal Ripken jr. breaks the [ __ ]
Lou Gehrig record thank you right
McGwire and Sosa go on this roid run and
all the owners all look the other way as
we all sat there's these [ __ ]
gorillas came up knocking this [ __ ]
racquetball with [ __ ] let
leather-bound fell over the [ __ ]
fence right and then what happens oh
[ __ ] George Steinbrenner comes back
from his [ __ ] suspension right and
with his [ __ ] money and influence
somehow convinces the [ __ ] goddamn
eye look at the interception and of the
game convinced his [ __ ] baseball that
it's ok for a team to spend 200 million
[ __ ] dollars and treat the bottom
third of the
like their own [ __ ] you know farm
teams and that's what the Yankees did
for 11 [ __ ] years alright and about
three years into that [ __ ] the Red
Sox did the same [ __ ] thing and we
both went out there with 180 hundred
ninety two hundred two hundred ten
million dollar [ __ ] teams littered
with stars from San Diego Kansas City
Pittsburgh all of these [ __ ]
Milwaukee Cleveland took all their
[ __ ] stars we went into their bodegas
and we raided their shelves that's what
we did
and we went out there with their [ __ ]
stars Royd it up and we turned baseball
into like a five team [ __ ] League and
[ __ ] the Yankees had a two hundred
million dollar team with free agents
from around the league that were
roided-up for 11 straight seasons and
they won three titles okay the Red Sox
did the same [ __ ] thing and one for
so I say this if Houston if they have to
give back their 2017 out Houston they
can't spend two hundred million dollars
right this is my buddy man Yankee fans
like but Bill what cake table is legal
just because Italy it's legal doesn't
mean it's fair
I mean corporations can [ __ ] donate
as much money as they want to every
political candidate out there it's legal
is it good is it good for democracy
isn't good for you when I lunch-pail
Louise no it is not so baseball was
[ __ ] up they allowed [ __ ] six teams
to do whatever the [ __ ] they wanted with
everybody else's team go in there
[ __ ] burn down their [ __ ]
farmhouses and pour salt the field and
take their best farm hands inject him in
the ass cheek with [ __ ] roids right
but the juiced up [ __ ] ball and when
they went out there and it was like you
know I mean and [ __ ] all these sports
eggs sat around and just watched it
happen it didn't all he sports oh I'm
sorry networks didn't say a [ __ ]
thing I mean the [ __ ] Yankees
whenever they would win a championship
ESPN who's supposed to be neutral will
be like and all is right in baseball
like wait a minute so the other 29 teams
are just the supporting cast the [ __ ]
are we doing right and then meanwhile
the NBA is going off the [ __ ] rails
right and then then they just keep
trying to recreate bird versus Magic
those teams that happened accidentally
into the Isaiah bad boy Pistons in the
[ __ ] Michael Jordan and the Bulls now
they tried to do that on purpose and
they let guys like Kevin Durant and join
the other [ __ ] team that they almost
beat in seven games now now you just
joined them I know that's a completely
different story so here's my thing I
don't have a [ __ ] problem that a tier
two City that couldn't go out and spend
200 million [ __ ] could not keep up with
the you know the bigger market teams
went out and did what the [ __ ] they did
I don't give a [ __ ] all right I don't I
don't have any [ __ ] problem with it I
think it's it's it's wrong it is
cheating but I really don't think what's
been going on in baseball for the last
15 years has actually been on the level
and I think that they've tried to fix it
am I is my thing I really believe that
like all sports at this point especially
just because of the competition that's
out there as far as you know you kids
today you can play video games you can
stream you can literally whether they
call it cord cutting you don't about
that [ __ ] cable anymore and just have
your apps and you can just disappear out
of the sports world and that scares the
[ __ ] out of them okay cuz these guys you
know they got wives too got mistresses
they got yachts they got teams and they
got stadiums they got all of this [ __ ]
they they got a big [ __ ] nut so they
need you guys to pay attention so I
really believe that what they do is they
manipulate they do what they can to make
sure that the higher-rated
teams the higher rated cities have the
best possible chance to end up in the
Big Dance the best possible chance to
have the bird versus magic game every
[ __ ] year i 100% believe that and i
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says you
cannot convince me otherwise all right
all the [ __ ] rule changes that
they've made to try to make you know
every game like NFL games are never over
like that [ __ ] game 27 or nothing
when I was a kid that game was [ __ ]
over
you know the Packers we're gonna at
least get within two scores make it just
close enough so you'd hang in there and
watch all the [ __ ] commercials yeah
every [ __ ] 15 years every Super Bowl
is a [ __ ] blowout now every single
one seems to come down to the very end
like I I don't know that's just doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense to me I just
think that it's it's it's you know and
I'm not saying that that those players
are involved I just think that they do
it through changing the rules okay where
you know you can't like that stupid
[ __ ] Patrick Mahone's run for a
touchdown he wouldn't have done that
[ __ ] 15 years ago they would have hit
tackled him like a [ __ ] running back
go back and look at the tackling on that
play like they are so conscious that
it's a [ __ ] quarterback that those
last two guys let him go through him
like like you like Heath like he's
[ __ ] there but er they should have
lit him up I don't know so anyway that's
that's my whole take on that thing and I
without a doubt I think that you know
they always like this host stupid thing
down in nothing I love to is this whole
[ __ ] thing down in Houston is that
it's alex core he was the guy you know
anytime people get caught they always
pick like there's always the Ollie north
guy like remember that you know arms for
hostages that whole huge [ __ ] goddamn
there's like three countries involved
all right like I believe it was us and
then given [ __ ] weapons to somebody
in the Middle East so he get hostages
out of the lot of Central America some
crazy guy what guy sitting at his desk I
don't believe for one second that the
ownership of any team didn't know that
you someone was cutting a hole and
sticking a [ __ ] camera although I
don't know the devices are [ __ ] crazy
now when the Red Sox got busted usin
[ __ ] and I watches a couple years ago
there was an investigation but I would
stop short of actually think they didn't
I don't think they wore a wire I don't
think they they think that's [ __ ] nuts
I think that they you know did what they
did and I don't think like you could
only have players involved so much
because think about it I don't think
every player knows that you the only way
you you just tell the players you know
you're not gonna be trading right may
how do you do that that's my thing okay
once you get it to that level like the
way players leave one team to another
how do you keep that under wraps if
everybody in the Astros knew that was
going down the amount of [ __ ] people
who at the trade deadline just left then
if they just had one guy [ __ ] leave
or one guy gets cut and then he gets mad
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] at SMU that
[ __ ] that football program
he gets mad and then blows a whistle
then you [ __ ] so I don't know all I'm
saying is that baseball has been [ __ ]
up for a long time and every time I go
to Pittsburgh it breaks my heart to see
the Pirates where they're at and it's
such a great sports town and then people
are like you know my grandfather took my
dad to the games and then my dad took me
to the games and now I want to take my
son to the game but my son doesn't want
to go because the Pirates suck every
[ __ ] year and the owners just take
the [ __ ] payoff
you know which is also on them but I
just you know I know it's not the way to
run a [ __ ] league so I feel like in
conclusion if you're gonna let top teams
spend as much [ __ ] money as they want
and then pay off the lower teams and
take all their [ __ ] stars it's
inevitable that somebody else is gonna
try to do something else to try to level
the playing field alright so there you
go there you go and I also hate to tell
you people have been stealing signs
forever forever it doesn't automatically
make you win that's another thing that's
another like I don't know I mean if you
can't hit the curveball you can't hit
the [ __ ] curveball that's just it and
there's another thing too
everybody knew what Mariano Rivera was
everybody knew he was coming with the
cut fastball you didn't need to steal
signs they still couldn't [ __ ] hit it
so I'm not saying it's not cheating but
like the level of weight that they're
putting this on why all of these sports
channels while they just look the other
way at what teams like the Red Sox and
Yankees and even the [ __ ] Dodgers all
the money that they spent the [ __ ]
people that they've signed and all of
that [ __ ] these super [ __ ] teams that
have put together they're acting like
it's competition is it's [ __ ] so
which is why I do like the NFL as much
as I do feel it's finesse Terry Bradshaw
crushing that hat that's a great [ __ ]
hat I feel like you know I feel like
that was just desserts that that [ __ ]
happened I still think it's [ __ ] I
mean it's definitely [ __ ] cheating
but I mean come on help me man am I
really gonna sit here as a Red Sox fan
and act like the fact that you know the
Red Sox Yankees and Phillies the way we
decimated the Cleveland Indians and we
all want titles you know with [ __ ]
was a Cliff Lee Jim Thome
Manny Ramirez
CC Sabathia CC Sabathia was complaining
on his podcast
I love CC but he also [ __ ] left
Cleveland and piled on with the Yankees
join those free agents and you know
there was a couple of high-profile guys
on that team that were on steroids you
know uh you know if you're gonna [ __ ]
about one you got a [ __ ] about
everything at that point right I'm
probably not making sense to you but
that's that's just how I feel that's you
know what this is just a guy who hasn't
played organized sports and [ __ ]
30-something [ __ ] years alright
plowing ahead here LegalZoom alright you
know it's easy to make the same old New
Year's resolutions that won't stick
speaking of which I want to talk you
about my [ __ ] attempt to quit smoking
cigars so change it up this year use
LegalZoom to do something impactful in
your life make 2020 the year you
officially start your business or you
can finally get your will or living
trust sorted out one of the greatest
things I ever did you know get yourself
a will get some life insurance give you
give your wife on motivation to put some
[ __ ] in your food that's when you know
your family's taken care of
alright over the past 19 years LegalZoom
has helped more than 4 million people
they provide the resources you need to
confidently resolve your personal and
business legal needs you can get started
quickly online and if you have questions
or need advice they have the right
people to help you out Legal Zoom isn't
a law firm so you can count on them you
can count on their network of
independent and tourney's for advice at
the right price since they don't charge
by the hour make twenty twenty a year
you'll remember for the right reasons
and use a Legal Zoom to help you out go
to legalzoom.com today and enter the
promo code burn in the box at checkout
for special savings that's legalzoom.com
Pro Mode code Burpee you are our legal
zone where life meets legal all right
and lastly but not leastly policy genius
it's January 2020 the year
2020 shows up a lot in science fiction
does it a lot of people predicted that
by now we'd be teleporting to work or
living on Moz and a lot of people a lot
of those predictions were wrong you know
it'd be great if they used
videoconferencing instead of making all
these poor people take these business
trips they could save so much money I
don't know why they send people on these
[ __ ] business trips when they could
all just be in the same room
I mean you FaceTime with your kids
anyway the truth is will will always get
the future wrong which is why we need to
get life insurance right that's where
policy genius can help policy genius
makes finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers to find your best
price you could save fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home and auto insurance or disability
insurance so if you're a science if
you're science fiction dreams for 2020
still haven't become science fact don't
get discouraged get life insurance it
takes just a few minutes to find your
best price and apply at policy genius
com policy genius we always get the
future wrong but get life insurance
right by the way what is that expression
red tape mean it's a lot of red tape you
know everybody uses that expression
where does it come from I find it being
a ginger I find it mildly offensive red
tape expression origin okay here we go
who says you don't learn all right it is
generally believed that the term
originated with the Spanish
administration of Charles the fifth king
of Spain and Holy Roman Emperor oh my
god this reminds me of classes that I
failed in the early 16th century who
started to use red tape in an effort to
modernize the administration that was
running his vast empire so how did he
use red tape Oh God
things often described as red tape
include filling out paperwork you had
any origins okay the red tape was used
to bind the important administrative
dossiers that required immediate
discussion by the Council of the state
and separate them from issues that were
treated in an ordinary administration
way which were bound an ordinary string
okay so I guess a lot of red tape meant
there was a lot of stuff that you had to
deal with immediately meaning it was a
big workload that's that that's just
that's just what I'm gonna go with all
right that's that's I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave it at dim right that good alright
so anyways old Billy freckles but a but
a boo I just joined a gym man I'm back I
worked out my shoulders holding up it's
a little sore whatever but I said a
couple times a day it's fine it's past
it's it's it's past the healing process
and now needs to be rehabbed so I
finally got there so I've been
religiously going to the gym and all of
that [ __ ] so I'm back in there and I
don't know there's a lot of [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] people working
out that are way younger than me and
when I watch them work out knowing where
they're headed where I'm at with a
[ __ ] up body underrated learning the
proper form when you workout you have no
idea what that's gonna do for you and
your [ __ ] life I see people out oh my
god I saw this woman as she was doing
these [ __ ] tricep things and the way
she would like slam her arm back and
like really like it wasn't fluid it was
really like every time she did it I feel
II thought [ __ ] arms are gonna fly
out of her sockets but I didn't want to
be that old guy be like hey there little
lady you want to take some advice of an
old pasty man so anyway I am seven days
in to no cigars I have quit them or I'm
on some sort of a sabbatical I I don't
know that I can just sit here and live
this
monastery lifestyle you know I and no
booze no nothing no cigars no internet
porn I mean I'm trying to set an example
because I got a kid now so I'm just like
I don't know what but uh I you know
unfortunately I follow Laura cigars on
Instagram and every once in a while they
post a picture of a cigar and I just I
see I was like oh my god look at that
[ __ ] thing so I don't know taking it
day by day whatever I'll see I'm just
gonna go like a month and see if after a
month I I still give a [ __ ] or if I
don't I just need I need different
[ __ ] habits I don't know it took me a
while to wrap my head around never
drinking booze again like I'm never
gonna have a cold [ __ ] beer again and
after a while you just don't give a [ __ ]
so I I think I just have to get there
with cigars
that's a [ __ ] tough one so anyway
let's let's let's get on with some of
your questions here on the on the
podcast I did you know one of my
proudest things as a cigar smokers I
swore off Cuban cigars you know unless I
was with somebody who it was like a
known buyer of cigars had his own like
store and he went to Cuba and it came
out of his own personal selection then I
would believe that it's real but like
you know when it since I started smoking
cigars all these old cigar heads would
tell me like 90% of those things a
[ __ ] fake and I never believed them I
was like I you know he's just a [ __ ]
grumpy [ __ ] and they were right they
were a hundred percent right so what do
I know
all right with that let's uh let's get
to let's get to the podcast questions
here all right Neil Peart hey booze
basalt and blow hard bill as a
Rumer yourself I was surprised to hear
no mention of Neil Peart passing away on
your Monday morning podcast what gives
um you know what I kind of forgot to
bring that up to be honest with you and
then also I didn't want to do that thing
like you know when when like Nipsey
Hussle died and then all of a sudden
everybody was the biggest fan ever and
is so [ __ ] devastated
there was like major major major [ __ ]
drummers out there that I'm a huge fan
of and I just thought what they are
tributes we're gonna be you know would
be enough for you I didn't I didn't
think that you needed a tribute from a
casual fan of rush like I know the radio
hits I was more phil rudd ACDC guy I
know Neil Pierce one of the greatest
drummers of all time it's it's a [ __ ]
huge loss but I'm just not familiar with
their music enough to to do a tribute
that that man deserved I will say that
what I was really impressed with was
what he went through in his personal
life and to somehow get through that
remarry and have a kid was way more
impressive than all the unbelievable
stuff he did as a drummer I mean that
guy when it came to life he got the full
experience I don't think there was an
emotion that that guy did not go through
with the success of his band in all of
that type of stuff to like the worst
pain your heart could [ __ ] feel and
then somehow rising from the ashes of
that that was the thing that stood out
to him with me all right so there you go
okay and then I didn't want to be like
and it was so much [ __ ] on [ __ ]
Twitter me and people saying like oh you
know you know people like greatest
drummer of all time I wouldn't
the greatest I would put him number
three but still a maid you love all
these [ __ ] people like even when
somebody dies they have to do that Kunti
[ __ ] like putting people in like
rankings or whatever so I didn't I just
didn't want to do that okay that was it
all right listen to Joe DeRosa on his
podcast Joe DeRosa was a Hugh is a huge
rush fan so like he's gonna you know I
didn't want to poke my [ __ ] head in
and do that [ __ ] alright so they have
alright how was that was that was that
fitting alright so okay good news dear
Billy so birbal's first off you're by
far my favorite comedian loved the
podcast yadda yadda yadda alright thank
you
second I wanted to just watch your
episode on on the mandalorian I wanted
to just watch your episode of the
mandalorian you [ __ ] killed it thank
you
you truly nailed playing that smug
[ __ ] how long did it take to figure
out the smug part I see what you did
there seriously though I was impressed
since you always seem to get nothing but
bad news with no solution on here I
decided to give you some good news for a
change based on this article from the
New York Times 2019 was literally the
best year ever
according to the article every single
day in 2019 170,000 people moved out of
extreme poverty Wow
200,000 people got running water three
hundred twenty five thousand people got
electricity for the first time 650,000
people got the got internet access in
addition infant mortality which was 27%
in 1950 has dropped to only four percent
all right well it depends on what side
of the nature you are on this
not to see that human-beings quality of
life has seemed to get even better
I would love to have cede something in
there about solar panels electric cars
population dropping something about
global warming but it's good it is good
you know I like when good things happen
to people but I'm hoping there's this
new guy [ __ ] running for president
who's going like we're gonna go out
there change the world I [ __ ] approve
of this message I like what he's saying
I like those guys and of course
everybody's gonna be like well that guy
doesn't have a [ __ ] chunk is it
really gonna be Joe Biden Joe Blow Biden
with the [ __ ] I mean Democrats can't
come with somebody exciting Jesus Christ
last time Hillary Clinton with that
insane [ __ ] out of a horror movie
smile the eyes all wide craziness do you
akil's me about her and about so many
[ __ ] great politicians is how in
their head they get because they have so
many talking to her you should listen to
the Hillary Clinton interview on on
Howard Stern well she's just [ __ ]
chilling out you know I just think
because the press so picks apart
everything you [ __ ] say that you're
thinking about in every [ __ ] you like 12
words ahead of what the [ __ ] you saying
and then trying to figure out all the
ways they're gonna come at you she
sounded like a completely different
person and I remember hearing that going
like where is that person that's like
when I see a comedian who hasn't figured
out how to be themselves yet onstage and
you know they're in the greenroom
they're one person and then they go
onstage become somebody else but
whatever let's let's get Joe Biden oh my
god
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ Joe Biden
oh boy all right what is this a tune-up
fight for the real election all right
Amazon factory tour hey Billy Boo Radley
I mean I still like Bernie Sanders I
don't understand what people on the
left's problem is with Bernie Sanders
okay you got to fight fire with fire
like the Houston Astros they're gonna
[ __ ] have write it up free agents in
two hundred million dollars we're gonna
stick a camera on the outfield wall I'm
gonna level the playing field
okay the rights gonna have a [ __ ]
reality show TV star [ __ ] casino
owner with a toupee talking about
draining the swamp you gotta you got to
have somebody on the other side talking
crazy [ __ ] that's a good fight that's a
good matchup you gonna come with another
company man blowing a banker going up
there you can't do it alright hey Billy
boo radley big fan of the podcast my
fiance and I have seen you live in the
UK a couple of times and we can't wait
for you to come back oh thank you I
appreciate you coming out I don't know
if this is happening in the USA as well
but Amazon is now offering tours of its
fulfillment centers in the UK well that
sounds like damage control I think it's
incredible that Amazon are holding these
tours to show how happy and well care
for their staff are oh my god what ok
this guy says quote that guy didn't piss
himself because he was working to a
ridiculous time limit he just spilt his
free orange juice oh and this thing this
other spending in Amazon is the abusive
husband of employers and they're having
tours so that their staff can tell the
public that they just bang their face on
the bathroom door I'd be interested to
hear your thoughts next time you're
coming to Liverpool ask for some food
recommendations on the podcast [ __ ]
know where you ate [ __ ] knows where you
ate last time you were here all the best
to you and your family
yeah I ate at some awful places all
right let me open this like I got to
read this [ __ ] oh my god you know they
hand-selected happy [ __ ] workers oh my
god they probably like alright Turin
Amazon Fulfillment Center see the magic
that happens after you click buy on
Amazon . co uk by touring one of our
fulfillment centers in seeing firsthand
how we deliver for our customers search
for a location in book for yourself or
for groups of up to 10 people over six
years of age please for large group
bookings please contact blah blah blah
blah we call our warehouses fulfillment
centers i just how every time you think
[ __ ] corporations cannot be any more
transparent and I like how [ __ ] evil
they are a fulfillments that's what you
call a [ __ ] warehouse oh my god I
mean I just I in another life I want to
get into the corporate world because I
want to go into that meeting when
they're coming up with those names are
they sitting around laughing knowing how
ridiculous it is to say that somebody
working all those hours for that [ __ ]
[ __ ] pay is fulfilled boy do you
remember that really one of the worst
[ __ ] weeks in our life in the life of
the United States right around 9/11 when
they started calling French fries
freedom fries I mean and then the fact
that there were adults that laughed and
then thought that that was a good thing
I don't know I know here's the deal
I'll give you guys a little [ __ ]
story alright so a friend of
hours bought my daughter a doll in a
little bed you know for her birthday so
go put together the [ __ ] crib and
it's got one of those
what everybody call those those [ __ ]
those [ __ ] screws I call him for I
call him I always call him uh IKEA
screws you know those screws you got to
stick it across dowel nut one of those
[ __ ] things right so it's got like
you know has eight of those four up top
four in the bottom boom boom boom the
whole things together
no big deal well one of them isn't
machined right there's still a piece of
metal hanging in there so I'm like that
what the [ __ ] I'll go over to Home Depot
so I go to Home Depot right I'm walking
around you know [ __ ] you know
thousand foot [ __ ] ceiling giant
goddamn store I can't [ __ ] find
anybody finally find somebody and I hold
it up do you guys have these she's like
yeah we do
aisle 14 so I'll go over the [ __ ]
aisle 14 I walk down the aisle I find
another [ __ ] employee cuz I can't
find him and he's like I'm helping
somebody else like I'll [ __ ] upset
it's just like well listen buddy I get
it everybody approaches you cuz you only
have six people walk in the [ __ ]
floor it seems so he comes back I go
yeah do you have these and he goes nope
we don't make those here so I'm like
what the [ __ ]
the lady just said you have well she was
wrong right okay great so then he's like
I don't know he helps you find out what
size it is so then I go online you can't
[ __ ] find it so instead I go to I say
[ __ ] this I go to this mom-and-pop i'm
hardware store a little bit out of my
way I walk in there the guy [ __ ]
walks up he tries to find him he can't
find it you know he doesn't have him
something like [ __ ] so he goes I really
can i he takes me it back he sticks to
screw and a little [ __ ] vice he has
of course I'm thinking about casino at
that point you maybe pop your eye out
for [ __ ] was it something em one of
the guy's name was um and he just takes
a little [ __ ] hand screw thing and he
basically rethreads it for me it took
like 10 minutes out of his day he did it
and he goes out of work so I go to give
him 20 bucks he goes no no charge
come on take it he said no it's fine I
[ __ ] walk out and it thinks fine all
right that's what that's what I know
corporations just don't do that they
just have this it's so [ __ ] hostile
it's just [ __ ] you we're putting out all
the mom-and-pop businesses we're putting
them all out of [ __ ] business and
then you deal with us and you can't get
anybody on the phone and [ __ ] you and
then right when you get bad [ __ ]
will then have a tour and we'll have all
our [ __ ] miserable employees the ones
that we paid off to then sit there what
the [ __ ] smile on their face it's
it's [ __ ] horrible all right now you
know what the [ __ ] I was going with that
I'm in the mom-and-pop places when you
can do it all right okay I'm into
electric cars I'm into having solar
panels anything he can [ __ ] do to buy
to use less [ __ ] oil so different
parts of the world become less of an
interest for my own country so we can
somehow not go bankrupt here even though
we are already our bankrupt and maybe
that's the only thing keeping us afloat
I don't know all right getting too big
here getting too big for my britches
let's just get back down to earth here
face apps dear Billy good dad I'd like
to encourage you to keep your daughter's
face off of those dumb apps where it
looks like you you have bunny ears or
dumb sunglasses this is little there is
little that can be done to adults now
but these companies are storing faces
and cataloging them what evil will be
done with this information I have no
idea that's why it freaks me out I can't
figure out why this information is worth
tens of millions of dollars yeah like
listen all this [ __ ] that I bring up
okay there's people who are actually
working on it and like it's [ __ ]
crazies that they hear me talking about
it to actually have people who are
literally dealing with the [ __ ]
problem I mean I think you know I want
to talk about because it's too [ __ ]
crazy and big anyway someone would say
but Bill your daughter and the other
children's faces are being recorded
elsewhere
yeah but not an HD like with all the
permission given away by whoever
downloads the app in 20 years
they could say they
have time travel in versions of you
talking to yourself and telling you to
do crazy [ __ ] and you'll believe it
because you know they're close to time
travel by this point and the future
version of you will look really
convincing in whatever video message is
sent from the future
anyway look it up whoa wait a [ __ ] to
that go in 20 years they could say they
have time travel and have versions of
you talking to yourself and telling you
to do crazy [ __ ] and you'll believe it
does you know they're close to I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah I know I I listen I'm doing what
the [ __ ] I can hear go to mom-and-pop
places as much as you can and if you can
afford solar panels an electric car
that's I've been other than that I don't
know what you do and then try to stay
off social media and avoid screaming at
somebody you don't know because you're
not going to change their mind you just
gonna waste your time alright other than
that
keep watching sports or whatever the
[ __ ] that's sci-fi whatever the [ __ ]
you guys are meant to is is [ __ ] Rob
Lowe ever gonna age this [ __ ] guy
looks amazing anyway
heartbroken and disgusted at the same
time hey Bill I'm a 22 year old female
from Massachusetts been tuned in to your
podcast to add a laugh to my day for
about a year and a half I don't know
though that was just a wild [ __ ]
guess anyway I'm writing in on the off
chance that you give the urge to this
depressing email I don't want to read a
depressing [ __ ] email all right I get
it
times are tough out there right I have
spoken to my therapist who only states
the obvious family members even my
pastor about this and no one can give me
actual advice that seeps into my mind oh
so this is your Hail Mary okay talking
to some old guy who can barely read out
loud
alright take this advice at your own
risk alright oh wait a minute I I got
something to lift your spirits here we
go come on play it why won't it play
what the [ __ ] happened I was trying to
lift your spirits somebody else all
right okay here's the deal I I stick to
myself because I don't trust or like
people I find them boring unsatisfying
and mean overall I grow bored easily so
just focus on studies exercising sizing
diet and extra [ __ ] curriculars like
checking out guys no matter how old or
young and watching a lot of porn all
right here we go
this sounds like a Netflix series about
a [ __ ] serial killer I also got my
gun license recently out Jesus Christ
anyway one day at yoga a guy caught my
eye he pursued me and I followed it I
allowed it for the first time at age 22
I've been on dates but never called for
another one or like the guy well this
one dominated my every thought and I
actually wanted to have sex for the
first time okay all right oh boy fast
forward seven months later and we had
sex three weeks ago what then he slowly
started avoiding me at Yoga
switch Studios and says he feels weird
about seeing me because it isn't just a
hookup or a one-night stand and he isn't
used to having feelings oh boy I can
tell you something as a woman this is
died I think this is part of you of
being with guys in their 20s that's how
we all are you know we don't know to
just say listen I just want to bang you
I'm looking to bang that's what I'm into
right now I don't want to be tied down
I'm attracted to you I want to bang I
want to [ __ ] your brains out that's what
I if that's not what you want to do
don't talk to me that's what you do
believe it or not you can [ __ ] be
honest with people
and there's some woman out there who
also doesn't want to be in a [ __ ]
relationship but she wants to get banged
and then boom bang boom safe sex
great and then you leave each other
alone anyway I confronted him then he
said that I am expecting a relationship
from home which he cannot give because
he's too busy with work and he just
doesn't like relationships but he was he
pursued you for seven months I'm really
angry well you should be and worried
about him too
I can't focus on myself because of this
guy where does the gun come into all of
this uh boy I can't focus on myself
because of this guy he won't even answer
my texts anymore and I'm making a fool
out of myself I trusted him with my
virginity and he just turned away
because he feels something for me could
you get Nia's lady opinion on this too
as well as your own tough realistic
advice thank you Bill
and I would say go [ __ ] yourself but
honestly I cannot due to the level
respect I have for you by the way he was
30 oh all right unfortunately you're not
gonna go out into the dating world
without getting hurt all right and in a
good way it's good that you got hurt
like this in the beginning all right to
get it out of the way all right
and just because you had a bad
experience with this person doesn't mean
that you know every guy's gonna be this
way they're not you just have to find
the person you know that you should be
with which involves looking okay so you
got to get back out there I mean it's
just like it's like finding love is not
is the same as trying to make it as a
comedian it's not like you walk onstage
and you just know how to do an hour and
kill you gotta go you got a bomb
everything in life is just getting
through bombing anything worth having in
life it's just is that's how it works
all right you you have to go through
pain in order to get to pleasure to get
to success or whatever the hell that is
you want you got to work all right
and
so I don't know I don't know what your
gun license had to do with anything but
please don't don't do anything other
than target shooting or if you want to
go hunting other than that I don't want
to tell you yeah you met an [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] yoga class and you know I don't
know we've all been [ __ ] and it's
just I mean not now you got a story you
got a funny story to tell what the [ __ ]
you gonna do and I would I just keep it
moving I wouldn't waste any more time
thinking about that guy I mean if you
get outside the fact that you know what
he did to you I mean that guy's pretty
pathetic you know it could have been
worse he could actually [ __ ] got in a
relationship with them and married the
guy and had [ __ ] kids with that
[ __ ] and then he could have left so
you got off easy all right everything's
all good so I don't know I hope I'm
giving you good advice you just freaked
me out with the gun thing in the
beginning I'm not gonna lie to you I
really had nothing to do with the story
so I hope I helped you out I'm sorry
that happened to you and I just think
you know shake it off he knows beer
don't shake it off allow yourself to go
through the emotions what this guy did
to you it was [ __ ] [ __ ]
and cowardly and all that and he's old
enough he's [ __ ] or thirty years old
you shouldn't be out there doing that
[ __ ] all right
he should be out there [ __ ] do it
especially if it's your first time you
told him that and he still [ __ ] did
it
that guy's a piece of [ __ ] and you
should be rightfully be upset but none
of Europe being upset should involve
your new gun license if you know what I
mean all right with that you know go out
and try to meet a nice person yeah what
you're gonna do is you're the more you
date the more you're gonna be able to
pick out [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna listen to your gut that's
what's gonna happen that me the other
day I [ __ ] had lunch with somebody
and I just said to somebody afterwards
How well do you know that person he said
pretty well I go what happens when that
when her claws come out
and oh yes she has a temper bajas I get
that's what I thought that's that was my
gut she answered a couple of [ __ ]
questions and I was like little [ __ ]
a little hot sauce on that alright so
that's it I'm sorry
unfortunately in life you got to go
through pain and it's happening to you
but you will survive it and you will
meet a great person if you look but if
you stop looking you won't all right
it's all up to you all right sexist
comment oh Jesus Christ
hey there could be an alternate
alternate name for this podcast hey
Billy Red nuts my over 60 year old South
African boss got himself in all kinds of
trouble for commenting it's nice to see
a woman doing dishes to a lady at our
work you had no idea that it was it was
offensive or ye had to apologize
go [ __ ] yourself that's hilarious III
agree with that in my life it is nice to
see a woman doing dishes or cooking or
doing any of that they seem to like feel
that they are above that so many of them
you know and that guys should continue
to [ __ ] earn money and pay for [ __ ]
and wash juices and [ __ ] cook it's
ridiculous I I agree with that guy
I [ __ ] do 80% of the dishes of my
house it's just what it is all right hey
rice and beans hey [ __ ] nuts
my wife typed out her family's red beans
and rice recipe and sent it to me it's
easily the best I've ever had
oh there it is get the [ __ ] out of here
all right
oh we go oh my god oh we got some garlic
in there we got a bell pepper
I love celery I'll tell you one of the
best things at the farmers market is if
you get actual organic celery it's on a
next [ __ ] level because it's such a
forgettable [ __ ] vegetable right I'll
tell you when you go to a farmers market
that's like going into a cigar bar and
trying to actually find a real Cuban
everybody says what's in there is
organic and so much of it [ __ ] it isn't
it's really a Dutch master with the
[ __ ] Cohiba [ __ ] band
we got bay leaves cayenne pepper he had
thyme sage parsley oh my god we got some
sausage in there what are you [ __ ]
kidding I am making this [ __ ] baby they
heat the skillet that uh I like this
seems actually a little healthier too
cuz I don't see any shortening in there
that's what scared me
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm making this I love it I
love it okay anyway that is the podcast
congratulations to the Kansas City
Chiefs the people of Kansas City and the
San Francisco 49ers I am rooting for
Kansas City because I'm rooting for
their fans to get their first Super Bowl
chance however I don't think there's a
chance in [ __ ] hell that they're
gonna beat the [ __ ] San Francisco
49ers because it's going to come down to
defense and they just San Francisco has
a better one that's it
that's it and that's it I hate to tell
you but that's why I think's gonna
happen I hope I'm [ __ ] wrong I don't
know if I'm wrong you know what cuz I
love San Francisco and I love Kansas
City
two great [ __ ] teams I have to and I'm
just gonna root for Kansas City because
it's been so long since they won one
that's it alright that's the tale the
tape and I'm [ __ ] something-something
alright that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
and I will check in on you on Thursday
night